hi I'm Sam Alden is how to build the
future our guest today is sure how to
join thank you for taking the time
thanks for having me so you were in Y
Combinator with Dropbox in the summer
2007 that's right how did you come up
with the idea and end up at one key in
the first place well I had the idea it
was born out of frustration so I kept
forgetting my thumb drive the sort of
origin story of the company was when I
riding the Chinatown bus from Boston New
York and forgot my thumb drive and
couldn't get anything done on the trip
and then I had another problem which as
I added I was working on my first
company which we can talk about and I
had a real pain point around
collaborating with my co-founder around
the things that we're working on so but
his personal frustration I hacked
together all these script to try to fix
it but then that bus ride was the last
straw you were mentioned in the first
time you'd applied to white to you
before we were rejected you're rejected
for the first I would be the earth a
really good call it was a good call it
was so my first company is called
accolade and it was doing online SAT
prep because we realized the back in the
day of the SAT was changing and no one
had really built a good online course
and so started that company applied to I
see rejected largely because we were
both my co-founder with part-time on a
couple other reasons and market side
products and other stuff did you
interview what were you to protected
without it we were rejected without a
little bit while I don't think I knew
that and you didn't and you came back
the next step when I I got a little more
feedback from about what what happened
and some of the concerns were the one
they said about my co-founder and I
didn't know each other so well neither
of us was full-time on it market what
happened with Jago father we kept
working on the company until I started
Dropbox and then I was sort of drifted
apart
you applied to YC is a single founder
and then met a rush slightly after right
yes perfectly after so you talked about
that sorry isn't she
we usually these co-founder stories
start with my childhood oh we play a jig
already know a rush like only knew each
other for maybe two or three hours
before Wow it's routines except how did
you what gave you the confidence to be
okay with doing that a lot of funny so I
applied as a single founder to YC and I
got an email from Paul saying hey idea
seems interesting but you really need to
cut find a co-founder only problem
application deadline was like three
weeks away
yeah so that's like saying you need to
get married in the next three okay so
what happened was I is Kyle vocht who's
the 1-pounders of justin.tv which turned
into twitch and then started cruise so
far the only wife he founded with 2
million projects yeah so Kyle and I'm
the knew each other from MIT and we were
both on the entrepreneurs club together
and then he knew Arash they were floor
mates in East Campus on I might at MIT
was in Kansas and Arash is having a
pretty similar experience the one that I
was having which is we had friends who
had moved from Boston who dropped out of
school moved from Boston said um San
Francisco suddenly their companies are
raising millions of dollars taking off
and so I think both of us had a little
bit of cabin fever it's frustrating to
watch that happen yeah yeah motivate it
is um so she was literally two or three
hours yeah right together so we got
introduced Kyle sense there just told my
wife Stella's complainant Kyle I need
you know is there anyone great that you
know who could be a financial co-founder
because all my friends or
folks I was closer to just for whatever
reason timing wasn't right we're ready
to make the jump whatever it was and
then Kyle suggested a rush and so I
probably have the email somewhere water
rushes today let's meet up and we hung
out in Student Center for a couple hours
and keep dropping out of school the next
day it was pretty pretty well I had this
Takei was a special service blessing I
didn't even know this so you guys just
started working on and immediately
talked about the equity and went forward
pretty much so we've met up in the
student centered MIT he was he was
already pretty excited about the concept
of starting a company is doing YC and we
hit it off and I wish I could say that
oh yeah here are the 17 things I was
looking for and on this seven-point
scale for but no we just use I like the
kids clearly smart a little quiet but
very thoughtful and over time became
clear that this was a really good good -
how did you guys validate the need for
Dropbox I've heard stories all that may
be apocryphal that you posted on reddit
there so like if they wanted something
like Dropbox
well the first real test was I need I
made a demo video because it is
initially just to get into YC because
the whole Y Combinator application
process was pretty similar to the world
where I came from which was college
admissions and desperate and one of the
things you can do to give yourself an
edge in admissions was just do something
different so I need everybody to have a
demo link in their application or
whatever that would be but I thought
this was something that would really
that Dropbox was something really appeal
to the to the hacker news audience and
it was really get into YC where I made
this three minute demo video some music
equipment that
my band and I put on Hacker News estate
of the top hacker news for two days I
got the thing out looking for which is
the email from Paul thing I didn't want
was that you also need a co-founder in
three weeks but that was the first I
think we did that at least we did that
at least twice first again do I see them
to get some built in momentum around the
company there's this intimate intimate
comment either on that poster shoot when
you made probably that one where
someone's like I think the stupidest
thing I've ever heard of like don't
these people know that W gate exists you
can just use that no one needs a company
for this really we send that around to
other founders when they get demotivated
because people [ __ ] on their idea yeah
that's our better
oh we were getting it from all the
actions so actually we can jump to that
because I think that's a really
interesting point
one of things I respect most about you
is you have just like kept doing your
thing no matter what noise there is an
ecosystem about Dropbox or Dropbox that
whether it's like I don't need this
because I can use W get or just come and
go we valued or whatever and now you're
just like this behemoth and everyone's
like well we were wrong about Dropbox
how do you handle just constant
negativity from people saying this isn't
going to work for anything like that
well I think the first thing is you have
to recognize that that is always happen
and we experienced that from the day we
founded the company actually before that
and all the way to now and when you zoom
out you realize that a company like
Apple quarter after quarter can pose
like the best the most revenue much
profit of any company in business
history it's over the next day like what
they're really dead now so you have to
kind of get to appreciate that that's
human nature and that's just going to
happen I think work is a little harder
is you have to simultaneously have six
again and be able to tune things like
that out
you also have kind of thin-skinned if
your customers are unhappy or team's
unhappy you have to respond to that
so that's a weird dynamic
have to to handle but I think it starts
just getting super spected as that's
always going to happen how do you decide
when you need to address something with
customers or or team versus just let it
go in a normal course well I think the
well give you maybe women where this is
a fundraising context so in addition to
people on Hacker News a bunch of the
comments were negatives but actually a
bunch word plan our Center filed with it
we heard a lot of we got a lot of
pushback from investors saying hey look
this is Google's going to do this its
commodity online storage is kind of
startup cliches behind the way that
Bitcoin or other things have been and
frankly I agreed with them those like
yeah Google can probably do this yet we
don't really have a lot of structural
advantages yeah we're not really sure
how we're going to make money we don't
even have users and what if it's an so
that that's all true but that's you have
to realize that's like it's not causal
like this it's sort of just just because
other folks have done something doesn't
mean it's it and or done it in a way
that you don't think is good doesn't
mean it's inherently a bad idea let me
put another way I would ask investors
you use yes there are 50 of these things
out there but do you use any of them and
they would say no and I say hey guys I'm
not interesting with was this the
biggest problem that you
found in early days of just a level of
compositional presume competition in the
market or come because she didn't bother
me that much because our sites were also
a lot lower in the beginning and really
I had a target customer of one which is
really myself and victory would for me
would be never having to carry on a
thumb drive Hollander thank you from the
day you have the idea for Dropbox until
you had a product where you into the
lesson into thumb drive product ads it's
a couple months through six weeks six
eight weeks you know when it certainly
can make massive product progress like
that and but then it took a long time to
I can with a long time to make a
bulletproof and sort of save for the
world view so what were the big initial
problem so you say so what were they if
you think back towards like the few
times Dropbox almost died sure what
actually went really wrong so I think
that the early is early problems when
they're real problems were just keeping
us growth so we have inside the yet to
fill the prototype prototype works well
we made this video and we put it on Digg
and reddit and it just blew up which I
can talk about but then you need to
build a company because like you start a
product and you have eaten your okay we
have a product now we need users okay
let's go for your users a day and so you
always leave this part out of the movie
of startup yeah as well it's just you're
on this treadmill of that you have every
day if you do everything you were doing
yesterday just as well or better and
then you have much new stuff to deal
with
and so it's like okay what we need to
build the product we need energy Africa
voice before we need engineers before we
can get engineers I need to pay them I
guess that means when you do fundraise
okay we need to fundraise then we need a
lawyer an accountant to just the circle
keeps getting bigger and so you deal
with that by dividing and conquering you
you hire people and
but then you have a new problem which is
you're hiring people to do something you
don't know anything about suddenly it
everybody's running off in different
directions and so I think how hard
things were really keeping up with that
was the rate at which things were
breaking was was faster than we could
fix things and that was a really hard
thing to get used to because you're used
to especially if you're kind of used to
getting good grades in school and things
like that I've been or what said it's
well you said the average grade for
running a company is like a 22 out of
100 so when you're used to getting a's
it's a humbling thing and you have to
simultaneously keep two things in life
which is on one hand you really should
aim for perfection and try to make
things as good as they can be and not
when problems arise not tolerate them
but the things i'm going to recognize
like things you know it's like trying to
bake a cake in five minutes like there's
just going to be stuff on the wall it's
going to be a little screwed up no
matter how good you are and what you
really need to do and probably even
harder is your job as CEO changes every
six months every year of a couple years
there's nobody tells you that and in
fact some of the things that made you
good at the prior stage are become a
hindrance for the next stage so for
example I wrote most of the first
version of Dropbox and certainly rush
and I did together but there just became
too much stuff to do and I had to stop
coding I mean you're closed on writing a
book yes
Connor I think they've done some
analysis there's still stuff in there
and and a lot of how the core product
works is the protocol has been pretty
stable which is which isn't cool
I think there's although there's so much
advice online about how to start a
product there's actually very little
advice about how to transition to a
company so have anything else that
either is particularly good advice that
you heard or advice you now give
entrepreneurs who are trying to build
the next Dropbox about how to
successfully transition from an engineer
to someone running a large company yeah
so the first thing is that would have
been helpful in now Justin but first of
all nobody is born a CEO so that the
shot you you learn it and the challenge
is you just don't know what your blind
spots are and so you know how to build
at least in my case I grew up
programming I knew I could make the code
work we knew we could get people on
accra news excited about it
we knew we can make our early users
happy but if you want to bring a company
to scale there's a lot more that just
Ward is a lot bigger than a good product
and you have to be you be able to make
smart and fast decisions about what
markets do we go into our business
models competition strategy how do you
build a team how do you run a team
that's pretty tough when you've never
done anything so you don't really a lot
of context and I've been doing no Doha
sport learn a thing I think the first
thing you need is on the one hand like a
healthy paranoia ironically probably one
the most useful questions that I like to
ask myself and still do is one year from
now two years from now five years from
now when I look back on today what will
I wish I had been when or what would I
wish I had been doing and and so I think
really taking on yourself to be
systematic about how do I train myself
what am I going to need to know they say
you go from coder to psychiatrist which
I found is totally true politician in
the job and so and then there are a lot
of different points in between and so
did you mostly figure out yourself or
did you ask
like what what am I going to be doing
what will I wish I was on a year a
little of everything right so reading
was probably the single most valuable
thing that I did anything you'd
recommend other people read yeah and so
I think my favorite book on management
is high output management by Eddy Grove
which is kind of the Bible of how do you
scale an organization I might have a
very long list of recommendations but if
the effect of the executives by Peter
Drucker is really good but basically
what you're talking about you need to
have good judgment about a lot of
different things and so there's like how
do you what really is saying is like how
do you gain wisdom very quickly and last
book recommendation for Charlie's
Almanac by Charlie Munger is probably
the best book on that that I've done
I've read which is really about how do
you build a bunch of mental models to
sort of break down the complexity of the
world and in no one don't use each what
I reading as part of it but then also
having you sort of think about that
one-year two-year five-year who's having
friends that are one step ahead to
social you had five years ahead and just
short of looking at the deltas between
them and so I remember we had a coffee
meeting set up in mind Sequoia first
potential investors were really helpful
in connecting me with other
entrepreneurs and so I remember racing
out of the office running down the
Starbucks havin a seat and start
peppering with questions and I asked so
how do you how do you spend your time
what's important you and he's like well
it's really important that we have a
great mission as a company I'm like okay
and he's like and it's really important
that we have great values in a great
culture and I'm just like I'm starting
to tune out cuz I'm like remembering
which bugs I didn't fix and like did I
finish that before I you know committed
the code
and I'm like what the hell is this guy
talking about like this is none of this
has anything to do with our customers
getting code out the door but then you
start hearing that five or six at ten
times and you realize okay the only one
here who's confused as me um and so and
in that and then you realize we are
going from designing especially an
engineer you go you're going from
designing system code and algorithms
which is very orderly and discreet to
assist in the people and things like
culture values all kinds of other things
are the programming that makes that work
I think everyone's confused when they
hear that for the first time in it yeah
they think about code so if you found
any way to get entrepreneurs internalize
that earlier I never have I'm curious if
you figured out a way to it made what
these mean you have to live yeah I think
you might so I think it really need that
portfolio different ways that you can
train yourself so readings one
mentorship or getting advice from people
of different stages is another I like to
study just the history of business and
really excellence and so learning about
okay well it's one thing to know how
Google was built or how Facebook was
built but then you can learn a lot by
understand how does the consumer
packaged goods company run how does
Swift for either we like it
how'd you come up with a Swiffer how do
you think no competition there yeah I've
certainly learned the most from studying
businesses that are not in the
technology yeah I don't think people
often do them l-fatiha you know and you
want to go beyond business tip so how
would a Phil Jackson who bowl of the
Lakers the Knicks like so many
championships like how do you build a
culture on on a team like that how to
government's solve big problems and then
you can also lean on your investors and
and the board so for example Condoleezza
Rice is one of our board members she's
seen scale and all kinds of different
yeah environments from running the State
Department being Secretary of State and
85,000 person organization
she's Provost at Stanford
20,000 person organization and so on so
you want to triangulate from a bunch of
print sources which helps you
internalize these lessons more than if
you just read like a blog post about it
the most interesting meeting I had in
terms of thinking about how to build YC
in the last year was going to the
Vatican and listening to how they talk
about like I think on passing your time
frames and about a billion people and
it's like yeah it's a very different
perspective it was really good
what what is the biggest if you missed
our new coming today what do you think
the biggest opportunities are well I
think that the whole AI and machine
learning machine intelligence is going
to be transformative especially museam
out and I think things like when paired
with things like robotics just machines
are gonna take on a new role in our
lives which will have a bunch of really
interesting positive and negative
effects which we can get into I'm not
I'm not as worried about the robot
killing everyone's in the world that we
can a lot about that later good and bad
showing definite I think but I think
it's a really exciting time and well in
our world we've talked about Dropbox
evolving from keeping files in the sink
- keeping teams in sync which is a
little bit of a departure because when
we started we had this really our goal
to make it so nobody has to curious on
drive around again and life would be a
lot better if your stuff was in the
cloud and today this largely selfish
accomplished yeah mission accomplished
and but along the way we had opened our
i/o our eyes to a bigger problem when we
realized that for a lot of our happiest
customers it wasn't really the storage
that people were buying it was the
sharing and is a really using Dropbox to
get their team on the same page and so
what that meant a shift which we can
talk about a couple years ago we're like
I'll give all the things we're sort of
blessed and cursed was this original
product because we struggled in the
beginning to people like whoa what's
Dropbox or what Starbucks for and the
answer when you think about well what's
a computer for respect what's a file
tower so we have really supporting all
these different use cases but at the
same time it was very clear you in the
beginning that the role of files
in people's lives that are going to
change so in the beginning yeah maybe
you have text files and mp3's in your
Dropbox but in the world of iTunes and
Evernote and Spotify and Netflix there's
not a file to be seen and so you have to
really think the text just moves quickly
and so you always have to keep evolving
with the patterns unless changing what
was it strategic shift that you
consciously made that youth did you say
to the whole company some data in all
hands like we used to be a file company
and now files are dead and when I do is
our thing we did expand from okay
there's an expansion and then a
contraction which I can talk about so we
knew that files were going to the roll
file is going to change files when I'm
going to go away but they were going to
change and we thought about what what
place do we really occupy in people's
lives there are a couple big use cases
so one was private photo sharing another
was collaborating with a team on files
and then the third was with a platform
we do is a ecosystem of all these
developers and so we expanded to say
like okay well we're going to really
build separate things for photos because
that's a kind of a different product
we're going to do a lot more on
collaboration and so on and then that
was one we started to buy we bought
mailbox to start only something called
carousel so our photo app then in 2014
we stopped doing those things how'd you
decide to talk to Nina it was tough I
think what we found was first of all I
think it's usually make strategies that
look great on paper and when you think
about your overall market you want to
hold on to as many of these case as
possible and like so many worries are so
happy with things like sharing photos
this and we could do such a better job
there but the same time you look at
photos and collaboration it's like very
different products very different ideal
business model very different
competitions
everything is different and so we found
ourselves sort of straddling these two
worlds which made it very hard eh to
build the best focused product and be
just aminute hard for the understandable
we're doing and as much as like oh yeah
we were out in front of all this
competition sets in yeah and and I think
this is sort of a sense of we're doing a
lot of stuff it's not really working and
people just getting agitated and then I
reread a book called only the paranoid
survive by Andy Grove which describes
how actually Intel wasn't always a
microprocessor company that just started
in memory and they were getting crushed
by the Japanese and he talked about the
story of that transition from memory it
is to micro processors and as I was
reading it like my stomach started
churning because I'm like oh my god the
strategic inflection point is dying but
that's what we're in and there's a part
of the book where it says CEOs like to
keep their options open what you really
need to do when you're in the middle of
one of these inflection points is put
all your eggs in one basket and watch
that basket recording - Wayne's action
and so I walked in at 1:00 in the office
the next week and we're like we're not
doing carousel anymore not to a mailbox
anymore
with your audience or did the team get
behind you quickly I'm not a little of
both I think you find that in it and
what when your company gets bigger like
everybody knows it's not a secret that
some of these things aren't working the
way that you want them to and so in a
sense or two up to one set of people to
release and frankly like what took you
so long if it's obvious I told you so
it's very disappointing to do the letter
working on it which one Mimi here or two
products I really loved and it's
embarrassing publicly embarrassing now
something that change is that you know a
lot of problems in your company nobody
really cares about them except the
people in the company but when you're
when you go on the big upswing like the
one we had suddenly everything you do is
a lot more so peanut gallery is a lot
bigger and they press and just sort of
as the folks can be a lot basic there's
a whole machine that will build you up
and then I love they don't love to show
you now so and you again even if I'm
understand that and you can put that in
perspective it's very hard for the team
so but yeah that's the everybody loves
the idea of focus but what focus
actually means is like shooting stuff
you love and turning down things you
know you can make work but you know that
that's going to be part of the cyclical
nature of it every time you expand the
time to you when you contract
Steven the expansion one other thing I
remember I didn't know you really well
near other days of Dropbox but I
remember being impressed by just how
much you got done it's sort of like ads
Dropbox is really taking off and just to
wrap up to where everyone was using it
in like a one-year period
how did you manage your time like what
did your days look like and when you
went from sort of seven users to seven
million so sure so we the team I'm
thinking they have seven to seven
million we're probably we're trying
fewer than under 50 people and so I
think one of the is probably few things
that better than long I misunderstood it
or not clearly understood about our
state's which is first of all Dropbox is
part of the reason why we had two little
competitions for a while was droppers
looks easy but it's actually really hard
to do yeah and I knew this because I
wanted to just use the other product
like if any of them had worked I
wouldn't be here but it's actually
technically hard but what but that said
there were a lot of competitors who
built things that probably were
reasonably functional but they didn't
get distribution right and they didn't
get my reality right and I had been
paying attention when 2007 was kind of
when the Facebook platform did take off
and a lot of the gaming and you had
these companies which are gone from zero
Dondre
just that new land speed records were
set all the time and a lot of that was
through viral T and so there's a great
dave McClure had a great model called
startup metrics or pirates a ar-ar-ar so
I won't go too long about the basically
acquisition activation revenue retention
and referral that becomes like this was
how we manage the company right right
users come in oh my god
very few of the folks who signed up like
four out of five we sign up don't put a
file in the Dropbox don't install the
client what is going on we actually
brought people in off of Craigslist and
watch Simmons call the product maybe add
like a and we showed the video in real
time to the to all the or whole team and
the other one we're with the person in a
p.m. and one room the rest the team in
the other room we're like hey just sit
down
here's Dropbox go from here to sharing a
file zero of the five people succeeded
zero tiger and came close but really
paying attention to all the activations
our own example but all the steps and
because the viral engine like tuning
that as much as possible coming up with
things like the referral program and
which had this to side incentives where
if I give you if I tell you about
Dropbox you get free space like a free
space better of like 30% of our science
for a while
shared folders inherently viral another
20% so half of our sign of survival and
that was something that was like a new
that's something that wasn't well
understood before that time and it was
inspired but some of stuff I'd saw in
late 90s like PayPal or maybe early 2008
a large incentives referral bonus I had
the idea for the Digg and reddit video
based on a book called guerrilla
marketing which is like how do you do
marketing get users when you have no
money and so a lot of these things came
together at that time two of them some
dozen eight or a lot of the dots are
connected some things
over the last several years I get to see
where less than 50 people like you
didn't spend too much your time managing
the thing about the organization then
when you're like 20 people you can just
sort of manage my intuition or it's
manageable because you everybody can sit
in a room everybody knows whatever else
is doing but that transition to now we
say 30 40 50 people is very difficult
okay last question I won't ask you when
you're lying like but how do you think
about what's the decision framework for
staying private or going out looking how
do you think about that well I think
there's nothing nota something that
magical about it it's primarily a
financing decision and so it really
depends on geenie capital your employees
and investors need liquidity there's
some other benefits around branding or
and currency for exhibitions so on
what's happened over the last 5-10 years
is the private markets have found ways
to solve most of those problems and
going public as a way to solve all of
them however then there is operationally
it's tough for a couple reasons one
position a lot of overhead with
compliance and regulatory stuff that
really where you've a lot of people in
your company spending time on things
that don't really have anything to do
with your customers or your products so
there really is overhead there other
elements of discipline so on that are
good but it is a lot of overhead the
stock market tends to be
manic-depressives so they're either like
way more enthusiastic Vegas then they
should be about your company or way less
which creates these very it has a lot of
impact on morale but I think it's scale
the most most
companies are public and that's the
patchwork charting great well thank you
very much for taking the time thanks for
having me